صابر طفل لم يرى العالم كبقيه الاطفال
هرب من منزله من احدى الولايات السودانيه
متجهه الى الخرطوم لان والده السمراء ضربه
بعد وفاه والدته فلجا الى الشارع
المشردون في الخرطوم الفقر هو السبب الذي
قذف به من الشارع لكنه ليس الوحيد هناك
مشكلات اجتماعيه وصحيه ظلت تحيط بهم الى
ان وصلوا الى هنا كيف يعيشون وماذا يفعلون
وهل يشكلون خطرا على المجتمع
نجيب الفرن
[موسيقى]
يجمعهم الشارع يتشابهون في القصص يختلفون
في الاعمار وعمق الماسيسي يقولون ان
الدمعه تروي الكثيره من قساوه الحياه اما
هنا وسط هؤلاء فان البسمه هي البديل بسمه
لا مناسبه لها بلغه المنطق
قد يزدر البعض شكلهم المتسخ وحياتهم التي
لا تشبه حياه الناس لكن ما نلقادر على
تعليمهم او انتشالهم من هذا المستنقع
مستنقع الفقر والجوع والذل والظلم مرتين
ظلم الظروف
لانه ممكن المتشردين يكون عرضه
للمخاطر من تجار البشر من ترويه المخدرات
للاهتداءات العنف وممكن همزاتهم يكون
عنيفين ممكن يشاركوا فيه اي حاجه غير
قانونيه يتعزم منها المجتمع العربيه
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]